(mellow music)
- David look!
They're wheels!
- Wheels?
(foreign language)
- What a wonderful day to
be in the house of the Lord.
If you're here with us for
the first time, please stand.
What a beautiful family.
Glad you're here.
- How's your daddy like that new farm.
He growin' things good,
doing things right?
- Yes.
- (foreign language)
- But I don't like grandma.
- Grandma smells like Korea.
- (foreign language)
(snoring)
(tender music)
- (foreign language)
(shouting)
- We need to find water somewhere.
You got soil ain't wet,
you're gonna lose your crop.
- (foreign language)
(sweeping music)
- Oh, you pretty K boy.
Pretty K boy.
- I'm not pretty, I'm good looking!
(chuckle)
- Hello everyone, and welcome to
the Academy's Visiting Artists
Film Series on "Minari,"
a conversation with
writer/director Lee Isaac Chung.
My name is Janet Yang, and I'm a governor
at the Academy of Motion
Pictures Arts and Sciences
in the Producer's Branch.
I am also an officer chairing
its membership committee.
And now I'd like to introduce
to you Lee Isaac Chung.
Hello Lee Isaac.
- Oh, hello, Janet.
- The last time I saw you
was at the nominees dinner
for producers and directors,
and we were very wise to
bring back those like you
who were nominated previously last year
but didn't get a chance to
celebrate you in person.
So, I wanna take you back to that time,
because one thing that's
gone viral, I think,
on the internet,
is when you were informed
of your nomination,
and your adorable daughter,
who was fully prepared for the moment,
moreso perhaps than you,
what did it feel like at the moment
to be honored in that way?
- Yeah, that was quite a
(chuckle) strange time.
That was a year ago.
And we were juggling the
effects of the pandemic
along with this incredible
awards run for the film.
So it was this weird
thing to be going through.
I think that thing with my
daughter was the Golden Globes.
That's when that happened.
- Oh it was the Golden Globes,
I see.
- Yeah,
when the announcement for
the Oscars happened, I was,
honestly, I slept.
'Cause I thought, I don't wanna, like,
assume I'm gonna get nominated.
I'm not gonna watch the nominations.
And then I woke up and
found that I had, like,
hundreds and hundreds of texts,
and that's when I realized
something happened.
So yeah, it's just weird.
I never get hundreds of texts.
- (laugh) Well, you're
probably getting more texts now
than you did before it.
You also had been so celebrated
at the Sundance Film
Festival earlier in the year.
So, you probably got used to
getting a lot of attention.
And you hadn't made a film in a while.
Did you have a feeling about that,
and how far the film would
be embraced so widely?
- No, I didn't.
No, I'm not getting used to the attention.
(Janet chuckles)
Yeah, it's weird, 'cause
this one was a film
in which I probably was
thinking the least about, like,
would this get an award
or would this do well?
Maybe that's not true.
My first film, I was kinda like that.
And it was such a pure process.
And then I made two films after that.
And that kind of idea
of getting some notice
was heavily in my mind.
And those films didn't
turn out to do that for me.
So, I had a difficult go
at it for a few years.
And this film ended up being
almost like a swan song.
Like, I wondered if I
could even get it made.
It was maybe the last
thing I would ever write,
that's what I was thinking.
I went off to teach.
I was also Professor
Chung in Korea. (chuckle)
You know, I just went off and taught,
and I thought maybe I'll
never make a film again.
And so when I was given a
chance to make this film,
my whole idea with it
was just to be as personal as possible,
just to relish the
experience of making a film.
And just to go back to the purity
of why it is we tell stories.
Like to love people, to
get into their stories,
to inspire audiences.
You know, all these different
things that I just think,
cinema, when it's clicking
is so wonderful and amazing.
So, all the other stuff
that's happened since then,
honestly I wonder if it's real.
It's kind of unbelievable.
But I'm just so touched
that people, I think,
are responding to the joy and purity
with which we made the film.
'Cause I think we were all
trying to be very vulnerable
with each other and with the material.
So just to see people responding to it
has been really, really beautiful.
- Do you think it's a sign
of the changing times?
Because I am very encouraged,
as I think you are,
about the attention that Asians
and Asian Americans are getting on screen.
And I like to think
this is something that is not going away,
that it's just the tip of the iceberg,
and there's more and more
authentic voices that can be embraced.
Your film was a game changer.
Others in recent years have been as well.
I think it's no surprise, you
know, "Crazy Rich Asians,"
or "Parasite," or "Drive My Car."
But yours, it was such an intimate film.
And precisely because it seemed
so deeply felt and personal,
I think people widely loved it,
whether or not you could relate
to this particular family.
Do you see that as being a
sign of what is happening now?
- I mean, I appreciate that.
I do see a lot of reasons to hope.
I think "Joy Luck Club" did
very well when it came out.
I kinda feel like it's an issue in which
it's not just that audiences
are embracing films like this,
but it's that I think
we're being given more opportunities now.
And I think when filmmakers
of various backgrounds
are able to have those opportunities,
what we see is that
audiences actually wanna see those films.
And I think "Joy Luck Club" proved that.
And a lot of these films that
are coming out these days
are kinda proving that as well,
which has been really wonderful.
That's one of the great things
about all the platforms
we have to watch films,
is that it's truly made
things a lot more diverse.
- Yeah.
Well, your film was just a joy to watch.
The pain, the depth, the heart.
One of the things that
does make it unusual is
it doesn't fall into
any tropes whatsoever.
Because we have, for instance, on TV now,
there's three different shows
about Asian Americans who do martial arts.
And more power to them.
But yours was something
that took place outside
of an Asian community,
in the heart of the Midwest.
And do you think that added
to the relatability of it?
It is obviously related
to a personal story.
You probably have had
some time to think about
why this film has been just so beloved.
And do you think that's
one of the reasons?
- Well, you know, I
didn't go into this one
thinking about whether
it's marketable or not.
And I wonder if there are some stories
that get made because
that kind of gets put in
front of the cart in a way.
That's the horse that's
put in front of the cart.
For me, this was just
a very personal story,
and it comes from the way that I grew up.
And I wasn't putting the
issues first, in a way.
I was putting more the emotions
and the spiritual dynamics
of the story first.
Like, the idea of love within this family.
A family really trying
hard to love each other,
and having a hard time at it.
And I think
that's what it seems people
are responding to with it.
And I recognize that.
In a lot of films that I watch,
it's always the human
qualities of the films
that seem to resonate with me.
It doesn't matter where
those films are from.
For instance, I loved
"Worst Person In the World,"
you know, of this past
year, and "Drive My Car."
And these are very, you know,
films from other cultures,
but I still really felt like
I was connecting very
deeply with the filmmakers.
So I kinda hope that's
what it was with this one.
It's really hard to take
this as a case study for me,
even moving forward,
to figure out like, how do
I reach an audience again.
It's just, yeah, such a mystery.
- I think you do it with your
heart, like you did with this.
But several of the
characters in your movie
are, again, surprises.
I appreciate it
because I've seen just about
everything there is to see
about representations of Asians
and Asian Americans on screen.
But the grandmother
character, Youn Yuh-jung,
who gave that fabulous Oscar
speech (chuckle) last year.
She also is not at all your typical.
She's feisty.
She's not this kind of
long suffering grandmother
that's sacrificing everything.
She has her own life.
She has a troubled relationship
initially with her grandson.
How did you shape this character?
Is she someone in your life?
- Yeah, I think (chuckle),
before you came on, Janet,
I was mentioning just how
fictional these characters are.
But in this case,
(Janet chuckles)
I gotta say, I don't know
what a quote unquote
typical grandmother is,
because I was partly raised
by my grandma who came from Korea,
and she drove me nuts.
(laugh) She drove me and my sister nuts.
She loved to annoy us,
and do these things that
would just set us off.
And at the same time, she
was tremendously loving,
and she was really a best
friend for me growing up.
And she just wasn't, I dunno,
she wasn't doing the sorts of things
that you might expect a
grandmother to be doing.
She didn't seem, I guess,
like a lotta the grandmothers
who I met around me
in Lincoln, Arkansas.
So it was always hard
to describe to people
what my grandma's like.
And sadly, it seemed like
nobody else kind of knew her,
because she couldn't speak the language.
She spent most of her time with us.
So a lotta people just didn't see her.
And that was one of the
elements of this film
that I wanted to do,
was to kind of reveal this
person who I felt was invisible,
try to make someone like that visible.
- And what about your
other casting choices?
It just was like a
perfectly assembled family.
What were the challenges,
and who did you have in mind early on,
or who came late to the team?
- Yeah, so when I'm writing,
usually I don't have anybody in mind.
I had Will Patton in mind for Paul.
That was the only person
I had in mind as I wrote.
And I think Steven came on first.
And that was because we already
kind of knew each other.
He's married to my cousin,
my first cousin who grew up in Arkansas.
So we kinda knew each other.
But we also started to be
represented by the same agent
around the same time.
And she kind of connected us
both knowing this project,
saying, "Hey, you guys should
work together on this."
And I was really scared.
I didn't wanna mess up a
family (chuckle) relationship.
And I wasn't sure if he'd wanna do this,
because he'd have to speak with an accent
the whole time as well.
And you know how charged that can be,
that sort of issue, for Asian actors.
So I was really pleasantly
surprised when we connected
and he loved the script
and wanted to do it.
So, he was the first Yi family,
person I had on my family picture frame
that I was building out as
I was prepping the film.
And I was able to fill in Youn
Yuh-jung and Han Ye-ri next.
And I was living in Korea at the time,
so I was able to meet them in person.
And Youn Yuh-jung was
just a dream to work with.
And I just jumped at the chance,
that if she could do it,
I would work with her.
So a mutual friend of
ours put us in touch,
and we met together.
I think she was only interested
in whether or not this story was real.
That's what she asked.
Like, is this a real story?
Yes, I'll do it.
No, (laugh) that was kind of it.
- Oh, and you told her
it was a real story.
- I did.
I mean,
(Janet chuckles)
I kinda told her-
- Little white lie.
- How it was written, yeah.
And then Han Ye-ri also
grew up on a farm in Korea.
So there was a similarity there.
So when we got together,
we didn't talk much.
Like, we were pretty
quiet with each other.
But there was just a shared comfort.
And I kinda felt like we
understood each other.
So that's how they came about to be,
like, those three got
involved in the project.
And then the big challenge,
to answer your question,
was finding the kids.
That was really tough.
We had maybe two months to find them.
And we knew that they would
be most likely non-actors,
people who have not acted before.
And we had this wonderful
casting agent, Julia Kim.
Just scoured Korean churches and hagwons,
and different places where
Korean kids are congregating.
And we were just looking for a Korean kid
who'd be able to speak in
Korean pretty fluently,
and also can act, (chuckle)
and all these other things.
So it was just a miracle
that we found both Alan
Kim and Noel Kate Cho.
They were just incredible.
We had them get together
on Zoom, kinda like this,
and just talk to each other
as though they're brother and sister.
And we saw them clicking.
And Noel was, like, asking him
if he did all his homework.
And, you know, she was
saying all these things that,
I was just watching, like, a
family conversation happening.
It was really magical.
And then Steven came
in for Alan's audition
and actually did some improv with Alan.
And Alan sat on his lap.
And I just saw a dad and his son.
And I thought, wow,
this is gonna be great.
So that's how we ended up going with them.
- And that Alan Kim, he's a superstar.
(laugh) He has a huge
following on social media.
- [Lee Isaac] (laugh) Yeah, I know.
- You said about two or
three things just now
that I wanted to follow up on.
One is the importance, I think,
of having a casting director,
having an entire crew, for that matter,
that really understands and
can relate to the story.
I mean, I can't imagine somebody
helping you with casting
and not being able to
get into Korean churches,
and knowing where to go and
developing a whole network.
I assume that was something
very intentional on your part.
- Yeah, there were many
intentional choices with our crew,
of specific times when we
needed somebody who's bilingual,
who's Korean, who understood the culture.
And Julia was one of those,
as our casting director.
'Cause she would have to
be talking to parents.
And she would understand the nuances
of exactly what we're looking for.
Like, which generation this child is,
when did the parents come over.
All these things have their own nuances.
And then the other was
we definitely needed
somebody who could speak
Korean as an editor.
So Harry Yoon, who we brought on board,
it was just so great to work with him.
And I remember some producers came in,
or some people from the studio,
and we showed them a cut.
And we totally forgot that
they don't understand Korean.
And we didn't subtitle it. (laugh)
And we're saying, oh yeah,
this doesn't make sense for you guys.
Because, you know, we were just able
to edit it in Korean and English
with that sort of shorthand between us.
So there were key moments
where we just felt like
we needed to cut to the
chase with that stuff,
just because we didn't have a lotta time,
and it would just help the
flow of making the film.
- Well I am, again, pointing
out how wonderful it is
to be working in this day and age
where there are enough
people to choose from.
When we were making "The Joy Luck Club,"
we definitely could not find an Asian,
Asian American casting director.
We had a few other roles for Asians,
but very, very, very few.
They just didn't exist at the time.
So, it's wonderful that we can crew up
and cast up in the ways that we'd like.
I had another question about
why you were living in Korea at the time.
And was it related to this film?
Because this obviously took you back
to some very deep roots.
And how did your time in Korea
affect the making of
the film, or vice versa?
- So, I went to Korea to start teaching.
I got a job offer to teach
as I was writing "Minari" in 2018.
And so it was a chance
to finally have some kind
of stability financially,
in terms of my own work.
And my wife had carried the load for us.
Especially because I had
asked for a couple years
for me to try to write something.
And so it was my time
to, you know, kind of,
I gave it my two years,
let's go ahead and move.
Going over there, what was incredible was,
one, I got to live out my
own immigration experience
of what that's like, to go
to a place I'd never lived.
And my wife, you know,
doesn't speak Korean.
She's Hong Kong Chinese.
We were going there with our daughter.
So we kinda were immigrants.
It was very different
from the way my parents
immigrated, of course.
A lot more luxurious (chuckle) for us.
But the other thing is we were placed in,
where I was teaching was in
this place called Songdo.
And it's in this area
with a lot of mud flats
off the coast of Incheon.
And that's on the western side.
And what I found out from my mom was that
that's actually where my grandmother,
who I wrote the character
in "Minari" after,
took my mom for about two
years after she became a widow.
So, my grandfather died in
the Korean War as a soldier.
And my grandmother took my mom there,
and she would gather
shellfish in the mud flats.
And that's how she
would, like, feed my mom.
And my mom hates shellfish
to this day, by the way,
(laugh) 'cause she ate so much of it.
But I had no idea that she did that.
And in my office, I could look out,
and I could see people, women,
mostly women going out and
gathering these shellfish.
And it's a hard living.
So it was strange for me to be there,
to think like, oh my grandma did that
so I can be here in this building,
you know, in the air conditioning
and doing something that's so much better
than what she had to go through.
So, I just felt a closeness to her.
And that really gave me a type of compass
as I was making this film.
- Mm.
Well, it's very apparent
that some deep connections were made then.
And having gone on that personal journey
also is quite remarkable.
The other thing you said earlier was
being a little bit nervous
about asking Steven to
speak with an accent.
Do you feel like we've come a ways away,
now that we have many more
projects and filmmakers
and talent that are surfacing?
Do you feel that it is now much easier
to make a film like "Minari"
and not be nervous about that?
Because we've gotten over
the extreme sensitivity
that existed when we had
so few opportunities?
- Yeah, I mean, I kinda
go both ways on it.
I do feel like there are reasons
to be optimistic and hopeful.
I still think it's a little hard.
Because, you know, I think before us,
"The Farewell" was being listed
often as one of the first
to have so much Chinese
language dialogue in the film.
And in many ways, they paved the way.
We often used "The Farewell" as an example
for why we can get away with
using a lotta Korean dialogue.
Because, to be honest,
there were hard discussions
in which there were
people who were worried
about us using so much Korean in our film.
And I think that it
also limited our budget.
Like, the fact that we
were shooting this film
for under 2 million.
That was reflective of the type
of film that we were making,
because it was not English language.
And then you signed the
release of this film,
just that level of confusion about,
is this an American film,
is this a foreign film?
So, my thought on it now is like,
you know, what Lulu did was
incredible, with "The Farewell,"
and that entire team.
I hope that our team,
as the "Minari" team,
that we also helped make
it easier for people
in what they wanna do
to tell the story that they wanna tell.
To prove that, hey,
there is an audience for stuff like this.
And also that you can create
roles that are, you know,
all different types of roles for actors.
And that they can be very
complex and interesting.
Yeah, I don't know if
that answers the question.
- No, it does, it does.
It's just interesting to
see how far we've come,
and things are changing.
There's still a lot of
anti-Asian hate crimes,
and so there's, in my mind,
good news, bad news every day.
Really good news (chuckle)
and really bad news.
It's not a straight line whatsoever.
But, you know, we do what we can.
And this film really,
for many people, I think,
was just another giant leap forward.
I mean, let's face it, Koreans
are killing it these days.
(laugh) Between "Squid Game,"
and "Pachinko" is another beloved series.
And so just, again, as
Bong Joon-ho famously said,
that one inch of subtitles,
if we can get over that obstacle,
so much more is available to us.
- [Lee Isaac] Yeah, absolutely.
- And it means a lot, I think,
for our children and our grandchildren.
What does your child make of this movie?
Have you watched it with
her, and also your wife?
And did they learn a lot
about you and your personal-
- Oh, there's a cat!
- Excuse me for my
(Lee Isaac laughs)
- Computer.
- I love that.
- While you were making this.
And how did it change
conversations you had in your own family?
- I do feel like it brought out,
working on this brought
out a lot from, like,
my wife knows me very, very well.
We have very open
relationship with each other.
And I think what it helped me with
was that I remembered a lot more.
And I was able to contextualize
things in my own mind
about my childhood as well.
For instance, like, I've
always kinda downplayed
certain things in my childhood,
or just not mentioned it.
But then I was able to say to her, like,
you know, I think my childhood
(chuckle) was kinda tough.
I had some tough times.
Like, half our farm burned down.
And we just kept going.
It's stuff that now I can contextualize
and think about my actual story
of things that I've lived through.
And I can kind of say to her,
okay, I think I have these
anxieties because of this.
So it was nice to work
on it in the sense that
I learned more about
myself with certain things.
For my daughter,
she just kinda grew up
with me making this film.
'Cause I was writing it when
she was, like, four or five.
And she came to set.
And she got to see the baby
chickens and all that stuff.
And then she got to see this awards run.
She seems immensely proud of
what's (chuckle) going on.
And yeah, it's just been
fun to share this with her.
To be able to do the work with my family
and not in spite of them.
Like, somehow to be together with them.
Like, they came to Tulsa,
and all the award stuff, I was at home.
I was doing these Zoom calls
for all that award stuff.
So I'd have an interview
with Hollywood Reporter,
then I would come outta the
room and they're sitting there.
And I'm, like, trying
to shake off my nerves
and all (chuckle) that stuff with them.
So we were together for all
of it, which was really great.
- And so I was wondering if
there's something you wanted
to share with this audience
about how you deal with your emotions,
and the mining of them for your work.
- Yeah.
There's a part in the film
where Jacob's yelling
and he's having a fight.
And he says, "I've been
at this for 10 years."
And he, like, bangs the table.
And that came out of me
writing at the coffee shop,
where I was going every day.
And I'm banging that into the dialogue.
I've been at this for 10 years!
You know, that kinda thing.
Yeah, it's strange.
When I was in Korea, I
sometimes tell this story.
I thought this film was
not going to get made.
Like, we got right to the finish line.
And because of everybody's
schedules, I was told that,
look, if we don't get this all
figured out in the next week,
this film is not gonna happen.
And if it doesn't happen
in this next week,
then probably it'll never happen.
Because, you know, this
actor has to do this,
this actor has to do that.
And then by then, it's like
maybe five years from
now we'll make the film.
That's kinda what I was told.
That reality meant, okay,
this film is gonna die.
And something weird happened,
was that I just hung out
with my wife and daughter that weekend.
And I just felt deeply at peace
and deeply grateful for them,
in this way that it just washed over me.
This feeling of thanksgiving and peace
on a very spiritual level, I'd say.
And like, I just felt like
I had no feeling of regrets in life.
I can move on now.
I realized I came this close to it.
It would've been nice, but
I have everything I need.
And once I had that feeling, like,
I just really said goodbye to filmmaking.
And then the next week, it happened.
We got the green light.
Everything fell into place.
It was late, but it just, like,
I needed to go through
that experience somehow,
on this cosmic level, I think.
And I carried that into this film,
'cause I felt like that's
what Jacob goes through.
And I've been carrying
that with me since then,
this feeling of an anchor,
of what it is that kinda
grounds me in this work.
And that's why I feel like
I don't get too anxious nowadays with it.
The truth is, like, the
fears are always there
for us in this industry,
as you know, Janet.
Even after success,
what you start to hear is,
you only have three years to make a film.
You know, otherwise people are
gonna start forgetting you.
I've been hearing messages
like that quite a lot.
And I don't have anything
that looks like it's
gonna go soon right now.
And there are a lot of reasons why
maybe I should be worried.
But yeah, I don't know,
that's kind of the anchor
that I've been having.
And I hope that offers
something for people.
- I'm sure it does,
because what I often feel
and try to talk about
is the spiritual challenges.
Because on the one hand,
what you did in that
moment with your family
was to let go, right?
Let go of something you were yearning for.
It brings tears to my eyes
to talk about it actually.
But, you know, you wanted so
desperately to do something.
And in the end, you have to let go.
Because you're not in control.
And sometimes just by the
letting go, things happen.
And yet, you have to maintain
a certain amount of faith
and belief in yourself
(chuckle) to keep going.
So it's really asking very, you know,
the journey asks very
different things from you.
Both to be thoroughly committed,
and then be able to
detach at a certain point.
So, it's a rather, you know,
it's like an accordion.
You have to expand and contract
with the circumstances.
But-
- Yeah, I think that's right.
And I think that seeking
out success in this work,
in film, in this industry,
in order to solve some deep issue,
I think that that's only
going to disappoint.
Like, even if you find success.
I honestly feel like
that's not gonna be it, so.
- Well, certainly if one
is chasing fame or fortune
or celebrated on that,
there is zero guarantee of that.
At most, we can achieve something
that we wanna put out in the world,
that we believe strongly in,
and hopefully connects with
the audience, is how I see it.
The external success factors
are simply beyond our control.
- Yes, absolutely.
- And it works both ways.
Things that seemingly
are going to be wildly
successful and are not,
or seemingly, and as in
the case of "Minari,"
very personal film that
broke a lot of rules,
becomes a huge quote unquote success,
in that it just touched people.
And that gives me hope,
is that sometimes the purity
of that reaction from others
is what carries the day.
And that's why many people just-
- Thank you so much.
- Are still
talking about "Minari."
And as far as I'm concerned,
you can take the rest of your life
to make whatever you wanna make.
There is no pressure.
(Lee Isaac laughs)
- Thanks, Janet.
- Do not feel any pressure.
It's not just three years.
I believe some students have questions,
so I'm going to take
some questions from them.
Are there questions?
If not, I have more questions.
So if there are,
oh, I see a lot of hands raised, okay.
Justin Park.
- Hello.
My question is that
it's very interesting to look at "Minari"
in respect to the first
film that you've made.
I'm not gonna attempt to say the title,
but the one that was set in Rwanda,
in the sense that
that is where you are almost
kind of there as an outsider,
kinda looking into their stories
and telling their stories to the world.
Where "Minari" is kind of
like almost the opposite,
where the story coming from internally,
from your own personal history.
Which is why what you said
about noting down visual memory
was so interesting to me,
because, I'm guessing
even the Rwanda film,
you may have not experienced
what they have experienced
and what they lived through
in contemporary Rwanda,
kinda the situation there.
But the visual memory from
the film, I'm guessing,
is still true to you during
your time you spent there.
So, could you kinda discuss a little more
about how you have navigated
different stories that you've told,
so far as filmmaker,
and how you think you will continue
to work on that navigation?
Do you see it as it's kinda like
an insider/outsider kinda type deal?
Or is there more kind of a unifying factor
that you have to your perspective?
- Yeah, thanks Justin.
Thank you for knowing about
that (chuckle) first film, even.
That film was so fun to make.
I went to Rwanda.
I had about, like, a nine
page outline of the story.
That outline was kind of based on
something I had read as I
was researching the country.
But when I got there,
I just started to really work with people,
and interview people.
And almost like in a
communal sort of sense,
we just shaped together the story.
We started adding different
people's memories.
So, there was that
similar element to this,
where a couple of the actors,
like, their actual stories,
the two leads in that film,
they would tell me things
that they've lived through,
and then we would incorporate
them into the film.
So we kinda did some of
that stuff with that film.
But yeah, I felt very comfortable
in Rwanda as an outsider,
in some sense, who felt like, oh,
I felt very home there, as well.
And I felt inspired by
the end of that project.
I kind of told everyone, like,
I need to go back to the US
and tell my own story somehow.
I remember that experience inspiring me,
because they kept on talking about
we wanna tell our stories.
You know, we just want more
chances to tell our stories.
So I made a decision when I left
that I'm going to try to help
them tell their own stories,
and then I'm gonna try
to tell my own story.
Like, there's some value in that.
It took me many years
to kind of come around
(chuckle) to doing that, though,
in a weird way.
But, as far as how I look at
what I'll do in the future,
I'm just kind of interested
in doing everything, in a way.
I'm not seeing any
limitation in that regard.
I'm not, like, a systems guy,
where I think systematically about things.
I just kinda feel things out,
and I'm just gonna feel out if
something feels right or not,
and do it.
And that's probably what
will drive me in the future.
And then what I also notice
is that I do the thing,
like, I make something,
and then I get really good at
talking about it in hindsight.
(chuckle) I don't know if
anyone else relates to that.
And I kinda wonder
if that's happened with
this film a little bit,
'cause so much of this film
was intuition, to be honest.
And then only later do I pick
up on some of the patterns
and different things
that I was thinking about
or influenced by.
And then I'm able to talk about it.
So, I don't like to go into something
with a concept in mind first.
I'd rather work heavily
on the intuitive side,
and then be able to figure
out what is this thing
afterwards in some way.
- Thank you.
- All right, Abraham Abatel?
Forgive me if I pronounce your name wrong.
- That was exactly
right, thank you so much.
Hello.
Hello, Lee Isaac.
It's a pleasure to meet you.
I guess my main question for you is
when you were in the early
stages of your career,
what was the one thing that
you wish someone had told you?
- Thanks Abraham.
Early stage of my career.
I have a lotta these.
Sometimes they're not as
helpful (chuckle) as others.
I think you might be asking this though
because you kinda wonder
with your own career,
and you're kinda wondering what to do,
and how your story might align with mine,
and what you could piece from that.
And it's just, my heart goes out to you.
It's such a difficult process with this,
with going into film, because
it's not an easy path.
And it seems as though so
much of this happens to you.
Like, you just happen to be
in the right place at the right time.
So, there's a lot of that.
I would say the one thing,
I think Janet alluded
to this so beautifully,
is that there's a principle
to why we're doing this thing that we do,
that can often be a guide.
Like, a belief in why we're doing it.
And I think that is what
helps make this path more,
it makes it easier,
and it makes it less
fraught with disappointment
if you're working with
certain principles of, like,
wanting to connect with people,
or do something good for
humanity, for society,
things like that.
If you're working with these principles
and you're chipping away at it,
I think that's always
going to be rewarding.
And it's always going to be
the right thing to be doing.
And it's the career type of
stuff that is really tricky.
It can help you get lost a little bit
when you put career success and all that
before the stuff that might
actually get you there.
And the stuff that might get
you there is actually, I feel,
your inner life and your
principles, and things like that.
I don't know if that answers
the question at all, but.
- That's amazing, thank you.
- [Lee Isaac] Yeah, thanks Abraham.
- Byron Hamel?
- Hi.
- Hey Byron.
- Oh, there I am.
(chuckle) Sorry.
So first of all, I'm
really excited to meet you,
and that's probably why I'm
pressing the wrong buttons.
This is such a great film.
I thought it was one of the best
family dramas I've ever seen.
But I wanted to ask about a
poetic thing that happens in it,
when David first, when
he cuddles his grandma.
And the next day, she's
starting to get sick,
and he starts to heal.
How much of that was intuition,
and how much of that
was something that you
designed poetically?
- Yeah, thank you, Byron.
Yeah, that was an idea
I had pretty early on,
that there's going to be a switch off
where we see David's journey.
He's kinda going up in his health,
and then Soonja, she's going down.
So at one point,
there's gonna be an
intersection for those two.
So, I was very much
thinking about that moment,
when it would happen.
And I felt like it should happen
at a moment that is very dark for David,
when he's really thinking about death.
I don't know why,
but when I was a kid, I
thought about death a lot.
(chuckle) It would stress my mom out,
'cause she thought, there's
no way a kid your age
should be talking about
death (chuckle) so much.
I guess that meant, you know,
I was gonna become an artist or something.
So I just thought about that memory,
'cause that was in my list.
And I thought, I think this is where
the intersection should happen with her.
And that was the hardest scene to shoot.
I never had a conversation
like that with my grandma.
That never really happened.
But there was something about filming that
and watching Youn Yuh-jung
tapping David's shoulder.
Every time I watched her
do that, I would lose it.
And I just kept feeling like
that was my grandma doing
that to me in that moment.
And I couldn't get through it.
And Locki, my DP, would,
like, hand me tissues,
and he'd ask me, "Are you okay?
"Do you want to move on?"
Like, we do something else.
And we had our schedule,
we were shooting so quickly,
I said, "No, we gotta do this."
But the sound guys are like,
'We're hearing the sniffling.
"Can you please calm down
a little bit?" (laugh)
It was just a tough day.
I can't remember any other scene
that was so hard for me to
get through than that one.
And even now I watch it,
and I think I wish I could
try it a little bit more.
'Cause I think I coulda made
that scene a little better,
but I was so, you know,
I was watching that scene
through blurry eyes.
It was, yeah.
- I don't think it could have been better.
For what it's worth,
I think it's one of the greatest things.
- Oh, thank you so much.
Thank you for that.
I was not fishing for that,
Byron, but I'll take it.
- No, but I did have one more.
I know, I don't wanna
take up everyone's time,
but did you give your real
grandmother your Mountain Dew?
That's my last question.
- I did not.
No, I did not.
For the record, I did not.
And yeah, I hope that ends up
on a Wikipedia page someday.
- (laugh) You can see people
clearly love this film,
and studied it very closely.
(Lee Isaac laughs)
Alright, Adam Boncif next, please.
- [Adam] Oh, hello.
Hi, hi.
- Hey Adam.
- So I'm actually not
Adam, I'm Alexis Brown.
I'm using my work computer,
so I apologize for that.
- [Lee Isaac] Oh, okay.
- But I really, really admire your work,
and I think it was an incredible movie.
And I had a question about
kinda like your process
and when you were writing.
And you said that you wrote 80 memories.
And there were, like, very bitter for you
from your childhood.
So with those memories and the
characters that you created,
what was your process in
coming up with the timeline
that kinda pieced everything together?
- Yeah, thanks.
I wrote those memories down on,
so I wrote them on an Excel spreadsheet.
I'm always like, why
do I tell people this?
But I did it on an Excel spreadsheet,
and I had them on different cells
so that I could cut and paste them.
And what I did was I took the memories,
and I kind of separated them
into the different characters.
And so once I had that, like,
each character has a set of
memories associated with them.
I would look at, is there
an arc that I could tell
of each of these character stories.
And not every memory ended up in the film.
I definitely whittled it down quite a lot.
But I definitely started with the memories
and then moved directly into character.
That's kinda where the
heart of it is for me.
You know, I try to map
out their whole lives.
I look at, if this film
is taking place in 1982,
then what was happening
when they were born,
what did they live through?
I go through that.
I have multiple tabs in my
(chuckle) Excel spreadsheet,
where I kinda put out
their timelines, and yeah.
So that's kinda where the process is.
It's heavy on the character side.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- That's a beautiful answer.
You're combining a little bit
of your earlier science training, I guess,
Excel sheets and tabs.
Very organized and structured,
but also very, very useful.
Sungbin Moon.
Question, please.
- Hi.
First of all, thank you for giving us
great inspiration and stories
during the discussion.
I'm an international student from Korea,
and I've been living alone here
in the United States for nine months,
with this dream of film.
Actually I saw this movie
on my first flight from
Korea to the United States.
So, it remind me of my family a lot.
And what I wanna ask is
how I can express my sincere
gratitude to my family.
Because recently I'm only
immersed in my sadness,
so I think I forgot how to
say thank you to my family.
So, yeah, this is my question. (chuckle)
- (chuckle) Thank you for that.
That's so sweet.
I mean, the fact that you're
asking that question, I think,
is going to lead you to the
answer that's personal to you.
And you know your family
much better than I do.
So I trust that's something
you'll be doing all your life,
trying to find how best to thank them.
I'm trying to learn that
too, with my own family.
How do I thank them,
how do I show gratitude.
And it's not always easy.
But I'm glad to hear,
like, what you're up to.
I feel like a lot of people
who have experienced displacement
and have moved to other cultures,
they make very interesting work.
There are a lot of filmmakers like that.
You know, Ang Lee was a
film student in New York,
for instance, from Taiwan.
And you could just see
his perspective on life.
It's different, but it's very beautiful.
And so there are many
examples of filmmakers
who have just lived in different places,
and who are able to tell a more,
I would even dare say, like,
a more universal story as a result.
So, yeah, much courage to you.
I hope your studies go well.
- Oh, thank you.
Thank you for answering.
- Lovely answer.
Emery Thanatitti, please.
- Thank you for pronouncing
my name very accurately.
(laughter)
- Yes.
- Hi, I'm Emery.
I'm also international,
except I'm past the student part of it,
and trying to make a
filmmaking career in America.
And so, I'm suddenly nervous,
but "Minari" is my favorite movie ever.
I think when I first
watched it, I cried so much,
because it really reminded
me of my grandmother
when she brought the things
back from Korea to home.
I'm from Thailand and Hong Kong,
so my grandmother would bring stuff
from Hong Kong back for us.
And I think it really inspired me to,
'cause this exactly the kinda movie
I've been wanting to create my whole life,
something that's about
family, about culture.
And I just saw in one.
So first I just really thank
you for letting me see that,
like, this could totally be a reality.
And I guess the question I
have for you is, as a director,
one of the things that
everybody talks about in a movie
is how well the pacing was.
And for me, a lot of the
arguments were really real.
I've experienced these growing up.
And the pacing for what they say on screen
and what they don't say,
everything in emotions were
like, just done so well.
How do you go about directing that?
- Thanks.
Yeah, first of all, thank you, Emery.
That's incredibly touching.
For the pacing of the film,
there was a lot that
was internal with that
as I was making the film.
When I was editing, like,
I would worry that I
didn't do it fast enough.
It's funny, like on the day,
normally when I'm directing,
I just follow my
intuition with that stuff.
And then later I figure out
if I did it (chuckle) right,
in the editing room, pacing wise.
And so I would say like,
I'm never the type of
director who has a stopwatch,
or looks at like how long things took.
Just whether or not it felt right.
And we were going for
something that felt
truthful with this one,
more than, like, the energy
of the camera movement,
or things like that,
that are actually really
important in other types of films.
But this one was a family
story, very simple.
So I was just trying to keep
it feeling real, in a way.
And then I worked with Harry Yoon.
And when I was editing,
he was really a compass for me.
He kinda had down the
pacing that would work,
the balance that would work for this,
because there's something
that happens for me
when I watch something way too much.
Then I start to wonder,
like, if it's boring,
if it's not working.
And for some reason I was
watching "Stranger Things"
and "The Mandalorian"
while we were editing.
And I kept thinking, we
gotta go faster! (laugh)
And luckily Harry was like, "No, no.
"We got this, don't worry."
And so Harry is like a brother to make,
after that (chuckle) experience,
'cause he kept me sane
and cool with what we had.
He kept reassuring me, this
is good, this is working.
In other words, intuition,
but you also need some people
to help you, in my case.
- Thank you so much.
- [Lee Isaac] Yeah, thank you.
- Okay, I see three more hands up,
and I think we're gonna have to,
if it's okay with you, Lee Isaac,
we'll take these last three questions?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Little bit later.
Okay. All right.
I'm gonna try.
Nicolo Esquivelzeta Sohn. (chuckle)
- Hi, yeah, Nicolo.
Don't worry about the last name,
it's such a difficult thing.
What an incredible opportunity.
Thank you so much.
I'm so grateful for this.
And I just wanna comment
on how your film was just so universal,
because I managed to connect with it.
Even though I'm not an
immigrant from Korea,
I am an immigrant,
and I thought that immigrant experience,
even though it was Korean,
it managed to relate so much
to the general immigrant ethos,
which I thought was fantastic.
And, well, I just had one question.
In an increasingly secular world,
I noticed that "Minari" relies
on huge themes of faith,
you know, and relying on faith.
So my question is, in an
increasingly secular world,
how do you manage to incorporate
faith into the narrative
without becoming too
cheesy or disingenuous?
- Oh, thank you, Nicolo.
To answer your question, yeah,
I would say I'm a Christian filmmaker.
Christianity and faith is quite
a big part of my own life.
And it was something that
I would kind of shy away from sometimes,
in terms of what I present,
because it's such a loaded sort of topic,
and it turns people off.
My intention with it
is not to proselytize,
or preach, or anything like that.
But in this case,
this story was so personal,
it was so much about the
things that I think about
and the way that I see things
that I just wanted to be true to it.
And that includes the very real doubts
and the ways in which that I
think I make fun of my own self
for the things that I believe.
So, you hear that all in the film as well,
those perspectives that everybody has.
And I think on a spiritual level,
everybody in that film kinda
represents some part of me,
my own spiritual walk and journey
and perspective on things.
In many ways, I'm Soonja,
who's telling her daughter to
stop preaching this nonsense.
I'm Jacob, who believes
using my own hands,
and using my mind, and all those things.
And then I'm also Monica,
who just wants to pray for people
and really believes and
hopes for better things.
And even crazy Paul. (laugh)
I have those sides of me too.
So, I was just trying
to be honest with it,
really exploring every character.
And loving them.
Loving that part of everybody,
and really respecting and honoring them,
and not criticizing any of them.
- Awesome, thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- All right,
Patricio Aramos.
- Hey guys, what's up?
Hi, Lee Isaac.
My name is Patricio.
Thank you so much for your time.
Thank you so much for this insight.
It's been really, really dope.
My question is
what film do you recommend
everybody should watch?
I'm currently looking
for something to watch.
Other than "Minari," of course.
Other than "Minari,"
(Lee Isaac laughs)
what would you recommend everybody watch?
- I'm gonna give a shout
out to someone who,
I just spent a few days with this guy,
and I gotta say, hands down,
he's one of my favorite people.
And it is Darius Marder.
And he made an incredible
film called "Sound of Metal."
- "Sound of Metal,"
Darius Marder, perfect.
- Yeah, go watch "Sound of
Metal" by Darius Marder.
This guy is the real deal.
- Okay, perfect.
I Googled it right now.
Oh, Riz Ahmed, nice.
- Riz Ahmed.
- I thin it's on-
- Riz Ahmed's an incredible guy, too.
- [Janet] Incredible performance.
- It's on Amazon, so
I'll be checking it out.
- If you haven't seen it, please watch.
- Perfect.
- All right.
- Thanks so much.
- Isaac Kau is next, and I
see Parvati just join us,
so that's absolutely the final one then.
No more questions please, after this.
- We have to take a question from Isaac.
- Yes, yes.
- Yeah.
- Hi Lee Isaac.
First of all,
thank you for being a great
filmmaker with the name Isaac.
Big inspiration to me.
(Lee Isaac laughs)
Yeah, I'm a Taiwanese American filmmaker,
so it's really cool that you
mentioned Ang Lee before.
I'm also Christian,
so it's really cool to hear
about that for your own story.
My question is for your writing process.
I've read up a little bit
on how you wrote "Minari,"
and the whole diving into memories.
And I think you've mentioned Dostoevsky
as inspiration before,
so I'm just wondering,
yeah, just writing inspirations,
who you would recommend reading,
as well as your own maybe daily
or usual writing practice.
And if you incorporate the
Bible into any of that.
- Thank you, Isaac.
Yeah, to be honest, I do
read the Bible every morning.
I was talking to another
writer, Min Jin Lee,
who does the same.
And there's a lot of inspiration in there,
especially the Old Testament,
which is just filled with such
incredible and crazy stories
that, yeah, you can see the
influence of it in so much.
But I'm wondering if I
have this book around.
One book I really liked
recently was called
"A Swim in a Pond in the
Rain," by George Saunders.
It's a really great book.
And I love Russian authors.
Like, Chekhov was a huge
inspiration for "Minari."
He has this story called "The Steppe,"
which is really wonderful.
But he breaks down how to read a story,
and how stories are told.
I think that book is really
invaluable for writers.
And then the question that you asked
about disciplines and practices,
I think that's really super important.
Like, let's say you only
have an hour in the day
that you can spare to writing.
It's kinda like exercise,
you only have an hour you can
go to the gym or whatever.
I feel like it's really important
to set that hour and be true to it.
Try to be as consistent as possible,
and do a little something
that helps you get into the
writing, ritualistically,
so that your body and
your mind knows that,
okay, I'm entering my writing space.
I'm normally not this
prescriptive about things.
For many years, I was just the type
who would wait 'til inspiration struck,
and then I would sit down
and bang something out.
And then, for many days,
I wouldn't do anything.
That was never helpful for me.
In retrospect, I realized.
What ended up working is
just sitting down every day,
even when nothing's flowing.
Even if it means you sit down
and you just drink a cup of coffee
and you're not doing (chuckle) anything,
and you're writing nonsense and gibberish.
Your body just needs to kind of realize
you're in that writing space,
and your body starts to help
get into that mode for you automatically.
This was especially important
after I had my child,
after my daughter came around,
in which I only had a
certain amount of time,
it was usually nap time
or something like that,
in which I could sit
down and do something.
And you'd be amazed by how
much that little discipline
can actually help you
to focus and to work.
So, I would highly suggest that.
And I see on the side, yeah,
it's "A Swim in a Pond in the Rain."
That's the title of the book.
So thanks for writing that.
Thanks, Isaac.
- Thank you.
I'm gonna ask one more question
before I get to Parvati,
because someone can not
turn her camera and mic on,
and I thought it was an
interesting question.
It's an African American
woman who says that
she noticed that "Minari"
resonated with so many
non-Asian people of color.
And what do you think resonated
particularly with African
American audiences,
especially since she
has roots in the south.
- When I was growing up,
we didn't have an African
American community around me.
It was quite a striking thing.
It was weird, like, I remember
I felt such a deep connection
to African American music and books.
When I would discover these things,
it gave me a sense of that
particular perspective
of someone who is on the
outside in many ways.
And I feel like we often relate.
There's so many things
that we are similar,
we have similarities.
Very strong families, sense of family,
that's multi-generational.
There are these elements.
The work of women being
so strong and vital.
Yeah, there are just so many
touchstones that, to me,
was always a deep connection,
that I wonder if that's
a source of connection.
I would hope.
Yeah, but I really
appreciate that question.
- Thank you.
Okay, last but not least, Parvati Devi.
- Hi, thank you so much for joining us.
And also, I just wanna say that
everything you've been speaking about
with your experience with filmmaking
has been really relatable,
which is really refreshing to hear.
- Oh, thanks, Parvati.
- Yeah.
I wanted to ask,
because "Minari" was such a
personal story for you to tell,
I think it's really
easy for filmmakers to,
like, when telling a personal story,
they want full control
over every single aspect
of the filmmaking process.
So they want to have full
control over the editing,
the way that the actors act.
I wanted to ask,
what is your mindset when it comes to
trusting the different
people to do their thing
and to fulfill their own roles,
while also being satisfied
with your own filmmaking?
- Hmm.
There's definitely such
a big part of filmmaking
that should, I feel, surrender
and yield to the creative process.
For me, that creative process is that,
filmmaking is a collaborative art form.
And sometimes filmmakers get into the trap
of thinking that that is
a threat to our vision.
But I view what we do
as being an incredible opportunity,
and it's something that
allows us to achieve something
that is impossible on our own.
So, case in point, when
we were making "Minari,"
I had a stupid idea, I'll put it that way.
That's the way I lead it off.
I had some stupid idea
about the production design.
And I got into a slight
argument with Yong Ok Lee,
our production designer, about it.
And then finally I threw down my card.
I was like, "This is the
way it was in my family,
"so let's just do it this way."
And then Yong Ok said,
"This is not your family!"
She, like, yelled at me. (laugh)
Like, this is not your
family, this is the Yi family.
And she was kinda saying like,
this family belongs as much
to her as it does to me.
And then she told me, you know,
this is why this is personal to me.
For me, that was kinda mind blowing.
It put me in my place,
where I realized everybody
has ownership in this project.
Everybody is bringing
something personal to it.
And because of that,
it's growing into something
that's so much bigger
than, you know, this small brain.
It becomes something much bigger.
And everybody was
bringing stuff like that.
Like, our lighting guy was
a white man from Arkansas,
who now lives in Oklahoma.
And he's an incredible guy, Steve Mathis.
He told me, you know,
"I took on this project
"because I also lived in a
trailer home with my grandma.
"My grandma kinda raised
me in the Ozarks."
And with his lighting,
there was something so deeply personal
about how he lit that mobile home,
in a very respectful,
dignified, humanizing way
that could only come from him,
in a way that, you know,
comes from his memories,
all these different things
that are just so beautiful,
So that's kinda the process
that I'm still learning as I go,
'cause inevitably I always think,
when you're prepping
something, you get worried,
so you wanna control it.
And you figure out,
this is exactly how we're
gonna execute the thing.
But on the day when you're filming,
it's those people around
you who really save the day
and show you better ideas.
So, that's part of the work
of being a director, I think,
is to recognize that.
And especially when you're
making a personal film,
where you can sometimes be blinded
by how personal it is to you
and how close it is to you.
The other people help
get you out of your head.
'Cause sometimes when
it's so close to you,
it's hard to communicate those things.
But other people will help
you bring those things out
in the right way.
Hope that answers the question.
- Yes, thank you.
That's something I will remember always.
Like, it's as much your film
as it is the other people
who are working on it.
- Exactly, yeah.
Yeah, you know, there's
nothing more rewarding
than when you finish
something, finish a film,
and everybody feels like
they own part of it.
Like, yeah, that's just beautiful.
That's exactly what you
want it to feel like.
- That is.
- Thank you so much.
- I think that's why we do
what we do, in some measure.
You know, the process of
creating something together,
and then having that result be shared
with others that we may not even know,
but somehow there's a connection made.
Lee Isaac Chung,
it has been such a
pleasure to talk to you.
You really share yourself
so genuinely and
generously and vulnerably.
And I'm sure everyone listening now
and listening later on YouTube
will really embrace so
much of what you said.
So, thank you, and I wanna
give a special thanks
to your wife and child for comforting you
(both laugh)
in that moment
when you thought you might give up,
and also to your parents and grandparents,
and everyone else who's made a life
that was so rich for you to mine
in this most beautiful movie, "Minari."
Thank you for participating
in the Academy's Visiting Artists Series.